OK, so now we know what CP
is, we can go ahead and build
one last tree using
cross validation.
So we need to make sure
first we have the required
libraries installed and in use.
So the first package
is the "caret" package.
And the second we need
is the "e1071" package.
OK.
So we need to tell the
caret package how exactly we
want to do our parameter tuning.
There are actually quite
a few ways of doing it.
But we're going to restrict
ourselves in this course
to just 10-fold
cross validation,
as was explained in the lecture.
So let's say
tr.control=trainControl(method="cv",
number=10).
OK, that was easy enough.
Now we need to tell caret
which range of CP parameters
to try out.
Now remember that CP
varies between 0 and 1.
It's likely for
any given problem
that we don't need to
explore the whole range.
I happen to know,
by the fact that I
made this presentation ahead
of time, that the value of CP
we're going to
pick is very small.
So what I want to do is make
a grid of CP values to try.
And it will be over
the range of 0 to 0.01.
OK, so how does what I
wrote feed into that?
Well, 1 times 0.001
is obviously 0.001.
And 10 times 0.001
is obviously 0.01.
0 to 5, or 0 to 10,
means the numbers
0, 1, 2, 3, 4 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So 0 to 10 times 0.001 is
those numbers scaled by 0.001.
So those are the values
of CP that caret will try.
So let's store the results of
the cross validation fitting
in a variable called tr.
And we'll use the
train function.
Predicting MEDV is the LAT,
LON, CRIM, zoning, industry,
Charles River, pollution,
rooms, age, distance,
distance from highways, tax,
and pupil-teacher ratio.
OK, we're using
the train data set.
We're using trees
(rpart), our train control
is what we just made
before, and our tuning grid
is the other thing we just
made, which we called CP grid.
And it whirrs away.
And what its doing there is it's
trying all the different values
of CP that we asked it to.
So we can see what it's
done but typing tr.
You can see it tried 11
different values of CP.
And it decided that CP equals
0.001 was the best because it
had the best RMSE--
Root Mean Square Error.
And it was 5.03 for 0.001.
You see it's pretty insensitive
to a particular value of CP.
So it's maybe not too important.
It's interesting though
that the numbers are so low.
I tried it for a much
larger range of CP values,
and the best solutions are
always very close to 0.
So it wants us to build
a very detail-rich tree.
So let's see what the tree that
that value of CP corresponds to
is.
So we can get that from going
best.tree=tr$finalModel.
And we can plot that tree.
So that's the model that
corresponds to 0.001.
Plot it.
Wow, OK, so that's a
very detailed tree.
You see that it looks pretty
much like the same tree we
had before, initially.
But then it starts to get much
more detailed at the bottom.
And in fact if you
can see close enough,
there's actually latitude
and longitude in there
right down at the
bottom as well.
So maybe the tree
is finally going
to be a linear regression model.
Well, we can test that out
same way as we did before.
best.tree.pred=predict(best.tree,
newdata=test).
best.tree.sse, the
Sum of Squared Errors,
is the sum of the best
tree's predictions
minus the true values squared.
That number is 3,675.
So if you can remember
from the last video,
the tree from the previous video
actually only got something
in the 4,000s.
So not very good.
So we have actually improved.
This tree is better
on the testing set
than the original
tree we created.
But, you may also remember
that a linear regression
model did actually
better than that still.
The linear regression SSE
was more around 3,030.
So the best tree is not as good
as a linear regression model.
But cross validation
did improve performance.
So the takeaway is,
I guess, that trees
aren't always the best method
you have available to you.
But you should always
try cross validating
them to get as much performance
out of them as you can.
And that's the end of the
presentation Thank you.